hi I'm Martha Stewart and today I'm
making beer batter deep-fried onion
rings from my new vegetables cookbook
there are many many different kinds of
onions in the grocery store and in the
farmers market nowadays and it's
important to choose the right onion for
the right job for deep fried onion rings
I suggest using the sweet large onion I
love white onions and I especially love
the vitaly I miss the big ones they make
really good onion rings I've been
cooking for as long as I can remember
being the second eldest of six kids in a
crowded family we learned at an early
age to enjoy all kinds of vegetables and
pretty much all kinds of food but if we
could get our hands on a homemade donut
or a beautiful french fried onion ring
well we were very very pleased I made
this for the grandchildren this summer
in Maine and boy they ate every single
onion ring look how great that looks
it's golden it's crispy I can see a
little tiny bit of the onion inside oh
this guy was hiding and it's not handy
at all is like you don't need ketchup
you don't need mayonnaise you just need
a little bit of salt and onion ring
Oh
[Music]